Religion according to Oxford dictionary
means a belief in a superhuman
controlling power, a personal god or
gods that deserve
worship and obedience.
In short, religion means
belief and worshiping God.
So if you want to understand any
religion, the best way is to first
understand the concept of God in that
religion,
it is not appropriate to try and
understand the religion or try to
understand the concept of God in any
religion by observing the followers of
that religion because many of times the
followers themselves are not aware about
their own religion or their own
scriptures. So the best and the most
authentic way of understanding any
religion or understanding the concept of
God in a religion is to read the
authentic scriptures of that religion.
So today we'll understand different
religions in the right perspective by
understanding what the scriptures of the
religion have to speak about their god.
I start my talk by quoting a verse from
the Quran from surah Aliman chapter
number three verse number 64 where Allah
says
say oh people of the book
come to common terms as us and you which
is the first term
that we worship them but Allah
that we associate your partners with
that we erect not among ourselves lords
and others in Allah. If then they turn
back
that we are Muslims bowing on to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala. This wash of the
glorious Quran is the master key for the
hour. It says
people of the book though it refers to
the Jews and Christians specifically but
this verse can be used to speak about
people of any religion. It says
come to common terms as us as you which
is the first term Allahill that worship
but Allah. One thing common
alhamdulillah in all the religions is
that the followers of any religion they
believe that almighty God which they
worship they believe is the same God for
themselves and for others.
The God which the Hindus worship they
believe is the same God for the Hindus
as well as the non-Hindus. The God which
the Christian worship they believe is
the same God for the Christians and the
non-Christians. Similarly, the God which
the Muslims worship, Allah subhana wa
ta'ala, we believe is the same God for
the Muslims and the non-Muslims.